I've always believed like I'm the
Michael Jordan of this industry when I'm
on the air I'm the one that will make
you want to hear from me you're thinking
from the employers standpoint the player
standpoint the media standpoint what do
you think of it we live in a society
where people have become masters at
pointing the finger at other people I'm
debating it hits people in Max's case he
has one lens this is it you come from
one place I come from a multitude of
places I was a Detroit traveling back
from a Pistons game and I got pulled
over and I got surrounded by eight cops
who truthy was the best at postgame
interview and Kevin Durant came out and
comes to the media he said well I could
do this and I could do that but I'm
Kevin Durant
I don't know who I ask right you used to
piss him up all the time I am NOT a
person that hides in studio who was it a
John Wall right it's 36 hours before the
season it was still overweight and out
of shape you cannot have TMZ having you
on video saying it's about you
he said Stephen a time to be out that's
a violation of my ethics you're trying
to paint me as something that I'm not I
will remember that
[Music]
if you follow sports you know I'm
sitting down with today Stephen a Smith
if you don't know Stephen a Smith and
you're in the world of business you've
got to learn how this man processes
issues and want to talk about that today
would that be and say Stephen a brother
thank you for making the time man yes
very good very good how you doing I'm
doing great it sounds like you had an
eventful day today so let me ask you
this high school I'm with you
10th grade 11th grade who Steven
Naismith skinny kid from Hollis Queens
New York striving to make it make
something to myself but very very scared
about life really coming from the
streets of New York City growing up poor
knowing that you wanted to capture a
level of success for yourself
and then wondering how you're going to
maneuver yourself through the terrain of
life and all that comes your way wanting
to play high school basketball targeting
a basketball scholarship because you
need a free education you don't just
want it you need it because your parents
can't afford to pay for your education
and also making sure that you stay away
from the game you know drug dealers on
the corner around the block in the park
etc etc and you stay away from the
allures of life the easy buck you know
you starving and okay I only got about
three outfits wearing the same outfit at
least twice a week never having a car
want in the car
I want those other things that going on
the wrong side of tracks could get you
if you're after an immediate
gratification and just making sure that
you're finding a way to avoid those
things incentivized by somebody that you
consider to be the greatest human being
alive that was my mom god rest her soul
and my family followed the sisters my
brother had passed away not at that time
I was he was still alive but he was a
traveling salesman before Dave was in
the military so just dealing with all of
those different things a father that I
didn't have the greatest relationship
with but he was still my dad just
finding a way to make it and trying to
figure out how I'm going to do it
because the only idea that I had is
basketball I didn't see another path at
that particular one since what age in
terms of basketball what age did you
fall in love with the game of aeschylus
from the time I started watching
basketball games I was four five years
old God I didn't realize I could play
until you know later on and so you know
when people started talking about you
and talking about your skill set and how
you could get a free education and
knowing that that would a name who you
did not have to depend on your mom in
order to pull it off you know that was
the target that was the goal if I'm in
high school with you were sending class
room together are you the guy that's
constantly debating I don't know about
that what about this how about this what
not this you were that guy I was always
asking questions I wasn't debate I would
say I was debating because the teachers
didn't allow you to necessarily do that
but I always had questions I was always
inquisitive particularly when it came to
politics and social interesting calm and
English I wasn't that strong in math I
wasn't that interested in that but I was
interested in stuff like political
science I was interested in politics I
was interested in some of the you know
just the things that went on behind the
scenes what led somebody to think the
way that they think articulated ellic
use their thoughts the way that they did
what were the kind of things that went
into that thinking what was the
difference between what you thought and
what you ultimately disseminated to the
masses
I always thought along those lines I
didn't have necessarily have the answers
but I always thought about it because
there was too many times I looked at
television and ice and I'm definitely a
product of the television generation the
too many times that I'd look at
television and I saw people who just
were not believable they were highly
credible but not necessarily believable
why because they tried it because you
remember back in the day before
commentary and pundits he really really
took off with this generation back in
the day everybody was cookie cutter
straight shooters you might have known
the facts but unless you could prove it
you danced that dance the dance of
neutrality and just straightforward
objective reporting as opposed to
editorializing and things of that nature
you didn't see the talk show format all
over the place like you see on this week
with George Stephanopoulos sure was this
week with David Brinkley you know when
you saw Peter Jennings or dan Rather or
Tom Brokaw the list went on and on you
saw a relatively straight shooters you
saw a Ted Koppel on new ABC News
Nightline straight shooter Sam Donaldson
covering the White House straight
shooter his delivery his presentation
his diction it cetera it came across in
such a way that you kind of sensed what
he was feeling but the facts that he was
spewing the substantive stuff that that
came moving out of his mouth
it was straight down the line there were
no chances with the editorializing and
that's what made an interest in the
first person that really really gave me
the idea of being able to editorialize
and opine was Howard Cosell that was the
first person that I saw that I looked at
which is why I loved him so much because
that was the first person that I saw on
TV and said I believed him no matter
what he says because he made himself
come across as very very believable
about whatever it was he felt you could
challenge it you can question it you can
object to it but what you couldn't do
was look at him and say he doesn't mean
what he says because you always knew he
meant what he said so so when did you go
from the level of curiosity where you're
asking because you're curious to now
having an opinion about things well I
would tell you that that didn't come to
a very very later on in my life as my
career evolved excuse me if you remember
I started off as a newspaper writer I
was a writer for the school newspaper
sake for the school newspaper and stuff
like that and I grew up in an age before
social media before the blog is fair and
what-have-you in so as a result you were
taught that you had to work your way up
to the point where you had a license to
editorialize and give commentary before
you were a general sports columnist you
are columnist covering one of the
league's prior to that you are a beat
writer or features right or
investigative right a reporter one of if
not all of those different positions
before you were given a license to
editorialize and express yourself and so
the objective and the goal all along
from day one was to ultimately elevate
yourself to be in the general sports
columnist and so I started off as a
intern and then I became a high school
writer for the New York Daily News after
interning at the winston-salem Journal
the Atlanta journal-constitution the
Greensboro News and record I was being I
was doing my job title was an editorial
assistant I did college i hi calendar
items the school lunch menus and things
of that nature from 8:30 a.m. to 6:00 at
night Wow
and then from 7:00 p.m. to midnight I
covered high school sports high school
football in the Piedmont Triad area for
the Greensboro News and record for free
I did that on my own time the goal was
to always accumulate published clips
because I knew coming from an
historically black college like what's
the Salem State if I was going against
people from Columbia to the University
of Missouri or Northwestern the UCLA or
whatever and it was their school against
my school my credibility would be
challenged because my degree was in mass
communications and it wasn't known for
journalism per se as an institution as
an HBCU while those schools were
renowned for having journalism programs
and so I knew that I had to accumulate
practical experience published clips or
whatever because if I did that then I
could walk into an office and sell my
work to a potential employer not because
my work was better or more gifted than
many people even though in some cases it
was in some cases it wasn't but it was
also me displaying my level of tenacity
and my commitment to being in that
profession because I knew and imagine
that an employer if he's looking at
somebody that has a laissez-faire
attitude per se towards being in that
industry and doesn't necessarily want it
I know every employer wants someone who
wants it I don't care who you are I
don't care what you're doing if you are
in a position where you hire somebody
the number one treat that you want to
see outside of their obvious ability is
to want it factor how bad do you want
this what are you willing to do to be
exceptional like this are you willing to
go to extra mile when is the job finish
is it when you punch a clock or is it
when the job gets done those are the
kind of people in any employer that I've
ever met has always wanted and I knew
that by showing my resolve and my
tenacity as a person that was willing to
work for free as a woman willing to do
numerous internships not surprising that
yeah what could they say and that's what
I did so when I showed up to an employer
for an internship or whatever I remember
when I first started in the business we
have folks with resumes I had 250
published clips coming out of college
how are you gonna beat that you got an
edge over everybody I got the and are
you seeing that a lot today as well
since kids nowadays coming out of
college or high school they have social
media so it's easier to have a resume to
show it's not easier today so the times
haven't changed for you I'm not seeing
that I'm not seeing that from the easier
or harder today I think it's easier but
I think that I think it's easier in
certain respects to be more accurate but
harder and others it's easier to
generate material that you can give
mm-hmm to a prospective employer to show
your commitment or whatever the hard
part is because it's so much easier to
do many many more people are doing it
and as a result you have more
competition than ever before so so let
me ask you this you know how you look at
in baseball you know you look at some
guys that do well because long-term
they're disciplined so I'm sitting down
with Billy Beane Billy Beane says
skillset mindset pedigree up
in strong family values then you look at
a planner say this may be somebody we
may want to invest in what what are
things in your world that somebody's got
to look at them because for you you
always say you know stay away from the
weed you look like a very disciplined
guy very meticulous obviously even just
watching you right now
very detailed and any have strong
opinions but it also you're not a person
that sounds like you wing it you
actually give your thought based on
doing some research what would you say
are great qualities in your world of
somebody to sit down and become good at
what you guys do well I think all the
things that you mentioned about Billy
Beane are applicable not so much
pedigree per se I think that when
anything that's associated with my
pedigree to me is about my mom my mom's
work ethic her willingness to sacrifice
her being the the mother of six children
and essentially having to raise us on
her own I don't talk a lot about my
father and I'm not about to now out of
respect and deference to my mother both
of my parents have passed away but I did
not have a close relationship with my
father part of the reason was because of
how he treated my mother the other part
of the reason was because of his
treatment to my mother and how it forced
her to have to work so much to take care
of us I am a very very very
old-fashioned dude in certain respects
if you can't do it you can't do it but
I'm one of those old-school
old-fashioned dudes from the standpoint
I believe it's not my preference to take
care of my woman it is my responsibility
it is not mine it is not just my job to
take care of my children it is an
absolute mandate my philosophy is very
very simple when it comes to my family
particularly you know me being a dad if
I'm hung if they're hungry it's because
I'm starving
I don't eat until they eat I don't not
comfortable until they're comfortable I
don't have unless they have that's the
mentality and that's the mentality that
I strictly get from my mother and so for
me you know having that kind of
mentality well what comes with that what
comes with that as a certain work ethic
that you have to put forth and it's a
willingness to sacrifice I'm not a most
disciplined person in the world
No am i the most meticulous person in
the world like some people would believe
no I'm meticulous enough and I'm
disciplined enough but I always also
know how to let go and relax or whatever
and sometimes I may not be as
disciplined as I should be
but I think the key thing is is that the
bottom line is everything to me
and whatever their bottom line requires
is what I'm going to do if the bottom
line requires an excessive level of
discipline I'm gonna do it if I can
slack off a little bit and still achieve
that goal I might pick and choose from
time to time to slack on just a little
bit yeah but to me it's whatever the
moment what a situation demands and it's
I'm a bottom lines oriented kind of
person I have an assistant I have people
who work for me I have people who work
with me they'll tell you I'm very bottom
line kind of guy if you tell me that the
job is gonna get done and the job is
gonna get done in an excellent fashion
and it requires ninety percent effort
I'll let you go with that I'll let you
get away with it I'm not gonna sweat it
but if this means if this means one if
this requires 100% and you give me 99 I
might want to fire you because I'm not
I'm about getting the job done sure
about yeah
the results and I think that you know
unfortunately when we look at our
generation today not enough people
preach about that you know they what do
you think that is because I think that
we live in a society where people have
become masters at pointing the finger at
other people about reasons as to reasons
why things don't get done I think
there's too much explanation that goes
on and you know I remember like I'm
friends with Gayle King I know Gayle
King Oprah's friend for a very very long
time I remember years ago she and I had
this argument because I always accused
stuff like that'll be in this Oprah fide
world that we live in and and I don't
mean that in a derogatory fashion at all
I love me some Oprah Winfrey she's the
queen and she's a goddess in my eyes for
all the things that she's done for
various communities throughout this
country but I do believe that generation
led by the likes of an Oprah Winfrey
introduced explanations in every
we can explain why this happened there's
a reason why this person acted up
there's a reason why they messed up etc
and I'm like no I'm not saying that's
wrong I'm saying some stuff don't I
don't need to know the reason why if you
are a murderer for example I don't
necessarily need to know the reason why
you are I understand that to do to do
diligence to put forth your research and
what have you and maybe we can study
this psychopath or what have you and
find out why they did what they did but
I don't need to understand all the
reasons behind why you did something to
know that you need to spend the rest of
your life in prison
when some people's eyes the death
penalty I don't need if you are somebody
that's a heinous individual that you
deserve a level of punishment I don't
need to know all the reasons as to why
you made your mistake before I need to
know that you're gonna pay a price for
it if you are a person that shows up to
work and there are a multitude of
reasons as to why you can't get the job
done I might be empathetic but the
bottom line is you ain't getting it done
and if you're not getting it done I need
somebody that can get it done and every
boss every employer that I've ever
worked for while some may appear on the
outside more empathetic more sympathetic
than others where they are similar is
the requirement and getting the job done
because they answer the people too and
so when you look at it from that
perspective and you have that kind of
mentality I am of the belief that if you
truly truly adopt that belief in your
soul do you walk to work every day not
looking for excuses you're looking for a
way for the job to get done and in most
instances you are going to be successful
then is that a transferable mindset
meaning there's a person have to be
willing to take that mindset to
internalize it or can somebody just say
I don't want to deal with it even in
your world they can do both they could
do both but I will assure you it is the
person that said they don't want to deal
with it it's not a person that's gonna
be successful at doing whatever that
respect yet you believe they can do they
can in most instances I believe people
can't because I don't believe that
employers usually put you in a position
where they know you will fail
if indeed their objective is success if
I'm a boss it behoves me to place you in
a position where I believe you can
succeed because you'll make me look good
why would I want to make myself look bad
so I'm gonna put you in a position where
I think you could perform you just can't
succeed and you can make both of us look
good but if you don't have that kind of
mindset and you are a boss that has the
kind of mindset it doesn't matter to me
what you do you're a good person I like
you but I know you're not qualified for
this job chances are that boss is not
going to be successful so one of the
things I like about you is the fact that
you sit down you say well you know max
we'll say something then you'll say well
I understand but even on this show we
have to understand that somebody can
come here and just because they disagree
with us and we disagree with them that
they're wrong and we can't have a
platform for them I think you and Max
have talked but even this was like three
or four weeks ago what why is it Steven
a that you when you're giving your
discourse your feedback whatever maybe
you're thinking from the employers
standpoint the player standpoint the
media standpoint the do you think that's
an edge for you because very few people
have the lens to look at it from
everybody's perspective uncomf-- or my
background I don't think they come from
opera so where does the employer
background comb allow me to explain I'm
relatively successful I'm certainly not
poor anymore but I've starved I know
what that's like so when you are a
person from a disenfranchised community
or dare I say a disenfranchised position
there is empathy for that but there's a
reality that that disenfranchised person
has to accept because you don't get to
change that you don't get to legislate
people's heart mind bodies and souls in
most instances they are who they are you
are who you are what it's important to
understand especially in this day more
so than ever before where the outlets
the tentacles that you have to reach the
masses it can give you a false sense of
empowerment disbelief that you can reach
anybody absolutely true it does not mean
everyone wants to
you it does not mean everybody's going
to care about what you have to say
there's a whole bunch of people with a
Twitter account they don't have 4.3
million followers there's a whole bunch
of people with Instagram accounts taking
pictures all over the place they don't
have 2.2 million followers there are
people that have 50 million followers
80 million followers but still people
will tell them to shut up enjoyable or
shut up and play your music and leave us
alone don't get into politics don't get
into this that what I'm saying is those
people might use their platform oyster
or attempt to use their platform to
disseminate a message about something
completely different and separate from
what they're attaching themselves to at
that particular moment in time because
that's what important to that's what's
important to them the problem is is that
at times you're touching on something
that is of no interest to the masses as
it pertains to what's coming from you
because they printed a pigeonhole when
Dave define your what they want to hear
from you and as a result if you step out
of that lane some might be receptive
some might lie and wait just to
excoriate you because they believe that
you're out of your lane so if you're
understanding that now transfer that's
in the business world I might have a
situation where you know what I think I
could do Monday Night Football
ESPN's like nope we want you to do NBA
well last time I checked I'm under
contract for ESPN not a contract for Fox
I'm not a contract for NBC here's I'm
under contract for ESPN so that's strike
number one strike number two they have
pretty damn good voices on Monday Night
Football who are far more qualified to
do football than I do strike number
three I'm pretty damn good at this first
day radio NBA etc that's generating
millions upon billions of the SPN well
what does that mean why would we want to
upset that applecart to put you in a
different venue that we don't know if
you'll succeed at but we're already
successful at so I can want what I want
I could
see what I can believe now I can think
whatever I want to think but do I have
the same the answer's no and the reason
why that's something that you have to
embrace is because in the real world you
usually don't get to make all your
decisions for yourself sure usually it
involves participation and approval from
other people so why talk to just one
segment of the population as opposed to
this segment this segment this segment
this segment it's everybody and when I'm
debating I think usually I'm debating
against people particularly for example
in Max's case who's incredibly
altruistic in this perspective and point
of view particularly when it comes to
the world of politics of social issues
he has one lens this is it well you come
from one place I come from a multitude
of places I've been there I've done that
and so I see all sides you're talking
about this owner I just had lunch with
him you're talking about this player I
just had dinner with him you're talking
about this particular athlete well
that's my man I've known him for 20
years you might be guessing you might be
right but I know and so as a result it
puts me in a position where I'm able to
deduce the difference between my
perspective an informed perspective and
a direct perspective where I'm impacted
by the parties involved all of those
things come into play and in my seat you
have to take those things into
consideration if indeed you care about
fairness was that you you've always been
like that or was it always so this is a
new work with skip and you and him clash
because off camera guys talk politics
Amitha yeah okay that comes that's your
mother - my mother was she was a she you
know I had a white grandmother a black
grandfather and my mother was not about
race at all believe it or not my mother
never mentioned my mother never
mentioned race one
in my house my mother never get her
house right you gotta be kidding me
never my mother my mother I can come to
her everything I come to my don't matter
mom they ought to get me what you do
what could you have done better I
remember I was in Detroit traveling back
from a Pistons game at the palace in
Auburn Hills all the way there Romulus
Marriott about an hour way in Detroit
near the airport and I got pulled over
by the cops and I got surrounded by
eight cops it was completely unnecessary
uncalled for they grabbed me out it they
told me to get out the car next thing
you know three different squad cars come
two in each car eight officers total I
had to white beat riders with me all
right from competing papers we were all
driving back together they handcuffed me
they put me in a squad car they took me
to the precinct Detroit Michigan and I
was pissed I couldn't I don't know how I
don't know if I've ever been that
furious I was because I thought it was
so grossly unfair and not only that I
knew I had paid the ticket so it didn't
make sense to me I'm like what the hell
is going on here and I was upset and
then ultimately I got out of jail after
about four hours bail was $250 I had two
hundred and forty-one dollars cash and
they wouldn't let me out until a dear
friend of mine who worked for CNN kept
calling them every five minutes until
they let me go I was nine dollars short
I knew the district attorney in that
town I wanted folks arrested I wanted
folks in trouble whatever I called my
mother she said but what did you do so
he talked why do anything she said
really what did you do I said mommy I
wasn't speeding I wasn't doing I didn't
do anything she said you did nothing you
sure about that and then I remembered I
was going like ten miles over the speed
limit
a and B come to find out I did pay the
ticket but I paid it late and so I got
there late which means it was in a
computer but there was a late charge of
$15 that I had it paint this system then
tell her it was $15 they just said he's
driving with a suspended license so a
turn attack that I served time in jail
for four hours in
Troy Michigan because of a $15.00 late
fee on a speeding ticket and my mother
said if you had paid the ticket on time
you wouldn't have it had that happen
that was my mother period she didn't
want to hear excuses she don't want to
hear anything yes people are gonna be
unfair yes people are gonna be a little
bit cruel yes people are gonna do this
and they're gonna do that how are you
gonna overcome it because if I set the
stage for you to have a crutch or an
excuse it's all unbelievable what are
you going to accomplish in life that was
my mother
so kept reinforcing taking full
responsibility regardless of the ones
your mom's birthday what month was your
mom 25th interest and your April October
14 67 right you're right very
interesting what what a and would you
say that - has stayed with you from that
day until today who you are as far as
your mama said nobody had a big impact
on me than my mom
and again we make excuses every day all
of us as human beings there's a reason
for that what ails and say you know the
travails that we have to go through
there's always a reason but I think the
thing where first take has appeared to
be so perfect for me is that on far more
cages than not I have to speak on the
issue of accountability as it pertains
to the entire sports world and when it
comes to the issue of accountability I
get all of that from mom it happened
with ESPN when my contract wasn't
renewed back in 2008 I was sitting at
the I was I felt betrayed I felt ticked
off and you know it I mean my mother let
me lick my wounds for a couple of days
and then she said what could you have
done bad you sure you didn't do anything
and I thought about all of something
like what is she talking about this just
not true that's not right I work hard I
do this I do that and then I started
thinking about it yeah I was a pain in
the ass I did kind of complain a little
good too much but the biggest thing that
I remember doing is that I always came
to the bosses were problems I never came
to them with some
hmm and I know me always like I was a
perennial complainant cuz I've never
been that that's not my style
but anytime I spoke to them about
something that bothered me my point in
making that statement is that it was
always about the problem never the
solution and I learned when I sat back
and reflected on the mistakes that I had
made in my career at the time I learned
that no boss wants to talk to anybody
that doesn't have solutions but that is
not true there's a flip step I've never
met a boss that doesn't want to talk to
someone with solutions see the
difference not if you don't want to talk
to somebody with problems and you don't
want to talk to somebody with solutions
then to me you're the problem
because you're not trying to solve you
want to go with status quo you're you're
perfectly fine you know fine with
flowing along say it alone or save
secure whatever but when you're trying
to win you're constantly looking to get
better and I realize as I reflected on
the first part of my career has been
from 2003 through 2008 to May of 2009 to
be exact I just said you know what I
didn't talk about solutions enough I
didn't talk about remedies enough and
I'm never gonna make that mistake again
so I'm gonna study and master my craft
my business first and foremost not gonna
talk about anybody else's business
unless I'm mastering my own and when I
have these conversations with them I'm
gonna come up I'm gonna have solutions
to any problem that I present them with
and if I don't have a solution I'm not
talking to them about my problem period
two good mindsets have Stephen a did you
ever have a either and I know you worked
at SI and CNN I think our once Tinian ns
are from 1999 to 2001 yeah did you ever
have any plans of doing politics or
sports or was always sports I actually
wanted to do politics um I certainly
wouldn't say I was an aficionado at it
but what I want I've always prided
myself and being a master communicator
that had a decent understanding of
current
and currently in current political
events and more importantly I was
incredibly confident and maybe is to a
fault
I'll openly admit but I am incredibly
confident when I'm on camera
I really believe always yeah all right I
really I really believe everyone's in my
way literally I mean if in simpler
layman's terms I walked around and I've
always believed like I'm the Michael
Jordan of this industry when I'm on the
air I'm the one that will make you want
to hear from me I don't care who I'm
gonna I don't care who it is it does not
matter than me by the time I finish
speaking I am the one that you're going
to want to listen to that's my attitude
I'm not saying it's factual I don't know
I mean we are number one but I don't
know but that's always been my attitude
because to me presentation matters how
you speak how you look when you're
speaking you know your cane in tradition
everything that flows with it I believe
I have the package and when I'm in front
of the camera I'm not nervous I don't
feel like I'm talking to millions of
people I feel like they're listening to
me
it's my domain big welcome to welcome to
my domain this is what I domine
what is your flow or structural
processing issues I'm curious because
you know the whole thing with first take
is do you something happens Antonia
Brown happens you know Colby Shaq issue
whatever thing that takes place do you
go and see what other people are saying
and then first stake here's where my
thoughts are somebody like oh you do
that sometimes sometimes depends on when
I'm coming on it they're like they are
sometimes like example when I was on the
new Sports end of the day I didn't get
to see anybody because I was doing first
take and then literally two minutes
before the sports in a hit they got in
my answer
stay right there sports and I need you
to do to do sports in it and that
happens a lot with me and my career like
ESPN will pick up the phone Stephen we
need you you know we need you wanna a in
an hour you
we need you here now you know so that
happens in an awful lot first take his
first take so I don't have time really
to watch other folks in the morning it's
it's rare that I get it is not always
sometimes I get to book 90% of the time
I don't get to see anybody so its first
taken I got to be ready you do your
research and what you do is you do your
research and you understand what your
job description is if I'm a newspaper
reporter I'm reporting if I'm a
columnist I'm looking for an angle that
I want to address and I want to attack
from an editorial perspective and one
first take it's the combination of it
all I'm editor realizing I'm opening I'm
informing I'm entertaining I'm doing all
of these different things that's I'm
just talking about my own individual
approach and so for me when I care that
when I'd know the subject matter we're
addressing first thing I do is acquire
as much information as I possibly slept
with step one step one I do nothing
before I acquire the information what
sources you go does it just stats that I
read I read everything I read the news
articles you know the New York Daily
News the Washington Post the LA Times
espn.com Yahoo Sports all of them I read
everything I get my hands on if it's a
particular athlete one of the first
thing I do is go to a local publication
because those are the people covering
them every testing because I know that
as a newspaper guy no one knew about the
Sixers more than me on a national level
locally you might have known as much
more from an app you're not there with
them every day
it's a disrespect to the reporters that
are on the scene to think that you know
what they don't chances are they know
more than you because they care about
more than intricate details that you can
you care when a big story comes along
you're caring if they trade a star or
you know somebody gets in trouble or
whatever you ain't following the dude
that signed a 10-day contract you're not
signing to do decide a one-year deal for
the minimum salary you're not paying
attention to those things like that cuz
it's not important on a national scale
but the local guys are and so for me
anytime
there's a story that's percolating one
of the first things I do is go to the
local sites because the local news pay
but is the local radio folks and stuff
like that will give you more insight
because they're around those folks every
day so that's part of the news gathering
then what you do is go about the
business of formulating your opinion
then after that if you have the time you
want to hear the opinions of other
people to make sure there's something
that you didn't miss but once those
bright lights come on your voice has to
be your own because to you to me
sounding like somebody else trying to
duplicate or imitate show ideals there's
a form of plagiarism directly indirectly
you know tacit or otherwise it's a form
of plagiarism be uniquely you and that's
what I try to I think historically I
think you're the one reason why fans
watch you I mean I'm a business can I
listen to first stage just because I
want to see how you're processing a
certain issue I'm more interested in
interviews postgame interviews than I am
of the game I know that sounds strange
I'm more curious than our people are
processing yet who did you think was in
the NBA best at postgame interviews what
did you enjoy listening to wow that's a
tough one but I'm gonna tell you that
for me personally Barkley was incredibly
entertainment to entertaining and Frank
not just when he was on TNT when he was
a player that's why he ended up on TNT
cuz mark they let you know how he felt
guys like Charles Oakley for example
they used to play for the New York
Knicks I mean it's just just no filter
if you stock you'd say so you know no
question about Shaquille O'Neal because
he would disrespect somebody in a
heartbreak the Sacramento Queens and
stuff like that but today in the modern
era that person usually would be
somebody like a Kevin Durant and the
reason why I would say a Kevin Durant is
because Kevin Durant has propelled
himself to a height he's a two-time
champion he's one of the greatest
players in the world he knows it and
he's not just more fearless than he was
in the past he's someone who loved
mence the fearfulness he spent years in
during when he first came into the
league so he's like you are I reflected
like looking at ourselves now and
realizing the growth and the maturation
that we endured and recognizing that boy
we wish we could turn back the clock
he's in a position where he feels like
he can turn back the clock and can't say
that was then let me show you who I am
now so you never know what he's going to
say but when he speaks particularly if
he breaks down certain situations you
know what you'll appreciate it for
example when he was going through the
first round series against the Los
Angeles Clippers and patched Billy spent
the first couple of games as an absolute
pest or a Singh mm-hmm and Kevin Durant
came out and comes to the meeting he
said well I could do this and I could do
that but I'm Kevin Durant I don't know
who I asked right you know who I am you
see now LeBron can be that way as well
but because LeBron was always held at a
very lofty status even though he's
critiqued and dissected more than almost
anyone the reality is is that he can
just talk naturally devoid of attitude
because he's just a polished individual
that came into the league that way and
needed to be that way Kevin Durant
actually went through a maturation
process where he wants to talk and he
wants to express himself and he's
literally you know begging you in his
own way to ask him a compelling question
that he wants to elaborate on because he
doesn't want to be silent I've never
heard you say this no no he doesn't but
I know I'm not heard you say don't ask
me yeah that's ooh no because I would
have never guessed you would have
secured the real ones ask me but but
what I'm saying is his intellect about
the game of basketball a URI is very
intellectual about the game yes but Kobe
was just a professor he can teach you
about school because it's so brilliant
about it but in Kevin Durant's case what
makes him interesting and again I
thought the Allen Iverson's the Charles
Barkley's all of these interesting Shaq
all these interesting and compelling
individuals that I've met over the years
and interview this athlete but the
reason why Kevin Durant stands out in my
mind is now right now is because he's
the one guy that I see
going through an evolution of evolution
where he's determined to sort of make up
with fearlessness for the fearfulness
that he had and that swarmed him at the
earlier part of his career he's eight
just to show you that he doesn't care
and that he knows more than you do about
the game of basketball at this moment in
time how do you think is gonna return
when he gets back how do you think ever
Durant's gonna be the superstar he's
always been you think and I think Kevin
Durant worst-case scenarios average of
25 a game worst-case scenario worst-case
scenario Kevin Durant by average 25 a
game on 45% shooting he's that great
Stephen a I'm surprised he didn't say
Michael so Michael and interviews
postgame interviews you don't put him
polish pop safe safe okay he did it he
did the talking on the court he had nyle
ated you he took y'all Michael Jordan
and his power came for what what he
didn't say like you know if somebody
hypothetically speaking cuz I don't
remember the exact quote but when he was
going against the New York Knicks years
ago and somebody said about him Michael
Jordan said you know okay and then he
had nothing to say then he finished his
interview about five or ten minutes
later and then he stopped on the podium
he said what was that what did that guy
say again and look at the media so who
said that okay thanks and that's it and
that had you waiting for the next game
because you knew Michael was coming for
him you said I'm saying yes just with
words it wasn't you said it's what you
knew he was thinking and what he was
going to do that's what made Michael
Jordan powerful but in Kevin Durant's
case LeBron and others especially of
Kevin Durant in this day and age it's
what he says and what he's gonna do
Kevin Durant everybody says he's too
sensitive he's just he's dead you know
he's got attitude every single time
Kevin Durant has had an attitude he's
dropped 40 have an attitude all you want
what do I care he's dropping 40 he's
driving 40 I was if if I had if I was a
coach or I were a team owner or a team
executive and I had a guy that if you
pissed him off he would drop 40 on you I
would be devising ways to piss him off
every week so based on what you're
saying is he's gonna average 15 points
when
comes back because you used to piss him
off all the time no I so now he's gonna
needs you you know someone Kevin Durant
very well Kevin Durant gets ticked off
very very easy if he sees one of us say
something or for us what I'm saying ever
no I'm saying
listen Kevin Durant and I get along I
just take the boardroom with him that's
kinda ya know what have you Kevin Durant
was arguing with me the day before over
something that I said he'll care he'll
just he'll just text me on Instagram
what the hell was that and he'll go off
about it how tough is it for you to give
your what's really on your mind knowing
you're friends with many of these guys
like even magic you know it's very hard
for it for you to be critical of magic
because when I see magic sitting next to
you it's as if it's your brother it's
your family pretty tight yeah it's very
obvious how tough is it for you to give
criticism to some of these guys that are
your boys or your best friend it's not
at all not even come on it's not even
look real ly because it's not personal
what do I say I'm not talking about
their family I'm not talking about their
particularly game you're talking about
the game like you know Allen Iverson let
me tell you something right now I'm
normal I'm tight with mm-hmm magic and
you know Shaq and your guys like Kobe
and others are cool and all of that
stuff and but Allen Iverson is like my
little brother with that tight and Lord
knows we had our history in each other
Allen Iverson I once once won eight
months without talking to each other
and I was the beat writer we walk by
each other they talk to each other by
eight months all right because he was so
furious at me and I didn't give a damn
but let me tell you something I would
never talk about his personal business
and he knows that unless one or two
things happened he asked me to where he
ended up in the police blotters because
I can't avoid that he said I'm saying
that's public information to me that's
not private can end up in the police
blotters is public mm-hmm okay
so that would be that that were those
are the only two conditions under which
I would deal with any of these guys
outside of that you have friends I have
friends you know I mean times we look at
our friends that was some BS right there
you could have done better you could
have played better you could have done
this you could have done that they know
this and so for me what I've religious
we made a point of doing is that I don't
blindside you the people that I really
really know I have access to so nine
times out of ten I'm texting them this
is coming
oh I'm calling you gotta be it's coming
Wow I don't like what you did what the
hell were you thinking you might not
want to see first take tomorrow because
I'm come what do they tell you now no
specifics but what do they tell you when
you say this is coming tomorrow man
there you go with that [ __ ] Stephen
a blah blah blah blah we start off given
a lot of times or they'll call and
explain themselves or whatever but they
always know at the end of the day I
might be a very insightful I might be a
Mac truck but you see me coming and you
know we talk about big-boy rules here
with big-boy rules in a world of
adulthood particularly as it pertains to
corporate America and things of that
nature people have a problem with two
things when you stab them in the back
but when you ignore them and don't
listen to them and you've given them no
outlet to influence your thoughts if
you're in a position like mine what I
try to do is make sure they never have
that problem with me if you are a person
that if you have access to me and I have
access to you there's absolutely no
excuse of my mind how I can take a
position without giving you an
opportunity to express your thoughts
about my position first now if you can't
be helped it can't be helped if I find
out something at 9:55 and I got to go on
the air 10:00 a.m. okay then I might
couch what I see a little bit what do I
do
I'm honest about it look I could go
harder but I got I know this person I
got in number I haven't had an
opportunity to call them let me call you
we'll hold back a little bit to give
them that respect to give them that
shirt because that's what I respect that
that's what I would want for myself yeah
but if I don't know you most times and I
will say this about me I blame you
I'm not blaming me because I am NOT a
person that hides in studio or others
cases they just say this before you
I go to the game right I go to the lock
rooms who was it a John Wall right John
Wall there was an where you don't try to
have a conversation with them he you
know listen let me preface my comment
about John Wall by saying he's a good
guy he's not a bad guy he just made a
mistake when he came to me cuz he's
lying okay he said um he was 36 hours
before the Washington Wizards open this
season he was seen at a nightclub
drinking and partying the problem with
that is that he came in the trade camp
overweight and out of shape it's 36
hours before the season people felt you
were still overweight and out of shape
and then on top of it all TMZ reported
you're looking at an individual right
over there that's the head of our social
media department he came to me and said
look at this TMZ is reporting this with
John Wall and had video so I said you
cannot have TMZ having you on video
saying it's about you that is what I
said he said Stephen a dime to me out
and told people I was at the club that's
a violation of my ethics I don't do that
I don't publicize your private business
now I might sit up there and see you
play like garbage the next night and go
like this what were you doing last night
as your game looked at man am i doing a
lot sure but that's about it I'm not
gonna sit up there and saying you were
here you were here you were there that's
your personal personal business I don't
do that why because I'm covering
athletes that are highly sensitive to
that kind of things and that's the
generation that I come from where
there's certain codes that you don't
break reporter or no reporter and I'm
very very big on that and so for me to
sit up the end and tell people that
you're trying to paint me as something
that I'm not I will remember
when I see him and whenever we have a
conversation one-on-one he's going to
know exactly how I feel and why I don't
want people interpreting either this is
gonna be more than that
mmm you know I'm 51 years old I'm not
trying to get into a fish or anything
and this doesn't warrant and I'm a grown
man but what I'm saying is don't do that
that's unethical that's not right you
know it's wrong don't paint me like that
what if I was that kind of an ethical
person where I wanted to paint a picture
of you you trying to tell me I couldn't
pull it off with the national platform
that I had but I would never do such a
thing because I owe that to myself my
family
Who I am what my name is over to my
employer ESPN to be far more responsible
than that very respectful on the way you
process that last thing cure Steven it
let's play again we're gonna play NBA
draft sure you got first pick all time
you got to put all your positions
together I'm gonna go set about we gonna
bop you you could say first pick I take
will Center you can get another Center
then you're getting four three two one
sure you got first pick sure who's your
first pick Michael Jordan
okay I'm second pick I got Shaq okay
third pick have Tim Duncan let's take a
live run this is prime prime everybody's
in their prime
yeah prime from LeBron is prime MJ I got
em James him done guys Shaq
I got Steph Curry really the greatest
shooter in the history of basketball yes
I'll tell you have Steph Curry
I'll take Larry Bird so you have LeBron
and bird mm-hmm we're Shaq mm-hmm I have
Tim Duncan Michael Jordan and Steph
Curry mm-hmm
see Kobe shouldn't be left off this list
but I don't need Kobe what's right I
don't need Kobe with MJ I'm gonna take a
while landed very interesting right
there quite Leonard let's go I would
take Scottie Pippen but Kawhi Leonard
was a better shooter okay I'm not saying
these are not our template I get it I'm
talking no no this is rap this is a
different game this is different gaming
game I'll take Malone which will own a
car Malone I put them four against Tim
I'll put so you have LeBron burr
call Malone who else chef and chef yeah
I've got a keema dreamed Olajuwon I got
Kobe that's a good matchup that's a good
squad who wins out of seven that's a
tough one
I'd say me you think so I have the
greatest shooter on the planet I have
the greatest player in the greatest
assassin to have ever lived and I have a
guy I have the big fundamental whose
money he would he would outplay a calm
alone he would outplay even a Kevin
McHale he can play center and I have a
guy on a keen to dreamed Olajuwon who we
all know what he brings to the table
you do have bird but you have a suspect
shooter particularly from the free-throw
line in LeBron James and you have a guy
that may be the most dominant force of
our lifetime and Shaquille O'Neal who's
also a liability at the free-throw line
not to mention had it given to him by
Olajuwon in his prime and so as a result
of that when all those Phelps I have
offense all over the place
I have defense with Kawhi Leonard with
Michael Jordan okay I got that going on
with a large one and Tim Duncan by the
way and when all those fears you know
what I can do that you can't refute at
all give the ball to us fails all I have
to do is value you've got two guys that
I can just file I can foul LeBron I can
foul
Shaquille O'Neal would that be your
strategy if it's no no there's no
question there's no question I it would
have to be I have a volume I got better
passes than you do though no year but
are they willing to pass who is the bird
will pass LeBron will pass the bird will
pass but he's a better shooter so sure
no no you know a bird is a passer but a
great shooter who's not gonna have faith
in the other guys ability to shoot so
he's gonna want to shoot more okay so
that's a problem I got Kobe who's a
volume shooter and he's gonna be his
egos gonna get involved cause he's gonna
want to take out MJ he's gonna want to
take out him - can't help himself can't
do it okay
he's gonna want to go after MJ okay it
doesn't matter who you have
I have the greatest shooter on the
planet in the history of basketball who
is at least 90% how's he gonna guard
over my one he's not gonna be can't
guard my one he can't play defense who's
your one up with LeBron a one okay you
can say that but again I'll just follow
and I'll turn them into a two-point
shooter and I have a three-point shooter
how many times gonna follow him doers
share you could say that I'm a foul on
when it counts
yeah I don't know I think it's some I'm
a Fowler when it counts he's gonna hit
threes for me Kawhi Leonard I can switch
I can switch and have him do that oh by
the way I can sit up there and put
Stephon Colby now Kobe will eat him up
but Kobe will take him down in the post
or LeBron will take him down the post
you have two point scorers I have a
three point assassin I have a guy in
Kawhi Leonard that shot 40% from
three-point range
I have elite defenders and Tim Duncan
Michael Jordan and koala a little law
with Olajuwon I got the dream shake he's
gonna go through chef I got the jury
excuse me nobody's gonna go who's gonna
go through shiny belt defense you mean
stop Shaq oh no just go through chef
when he's playing when Shaq's baby oh
yeah oh the dream did that already
ass Jack against Jack asked him out of 7
1995 do you homework
prime prime check him out prime prime
bill check him out prime prime Atta Shaq
was never but Shaq's Prime's done 95 go
Shaq would tell you the one person that
he would not want a god is a king the
dream put him against you and put him
against David Robinson put him against
anybody you want Shaq would destroy them
he has never uttered a disrespectful I'm
a word that came at you and by the way
my last point who was drafted number
three in 1984 Jordan yeah Jordan right
yeah the Portland Trailblazers drafted
who had number two Sam Bowie remember
how they thought they should have fired
those folks twice mm-hmm right Jordan
has six rings right
Hakeem Olajuwon only has two right
Hakeem Olajuwon I only had two when
Jordan retired sure from to go play
baseball that firm here Jordan was going
the second year he came back for 17
games left was taken out by the Orlando
Magic
any finals the Nick Anderson Dennis
Scott Shaquille and all of that stuff
right so that's six rings - two right
tell me one person in basketball history
I'm talking about as fans who've ever
knocked the Houston Rockets for taking
the game to dream Olajuwon ever because
remember they could have had Jordan but
they never took Jordan they took the
dream tell me one person anywhere on
this planet earth who ever uttered a
negative word at the Rockets for taking
oh absolutely not absolutely not if that
speak to your greatness what does let me
ask you in top-5 you put became ahead of
Shaq greatest forget about I think okay
I think I think the Shaq was more
dominant all right
but what I'm saying to you is I picked
the key because you picture I get it you
see and I think I think I'd be edgy go
with the center though I could have
picked will or whatever but what I'm
saying to you is that Hakeem the dream
Olajuwon could go tit for tat or
offensively but more importantly get
free throws so how can we do this is
there a simulator to put on a game to
see how that's gonna work we got to do
just to kind of get a feel but then you
can't figure out the bench cuz you got
to get the bench and all that going
anyways look if you if you don't follow
Stephen a and your business and somehow
someway you don't follow sports at all
but you want to find out how to process
we're gonna put the links below go
follow all her social media stuff and
see how he deciphers through issues that
can help you in any kind of business
investments entrepreneur CEO whatever
you're doing can help you out Stephen a
brother thank you so much for making the
time really enjoyed enjoyed it totally
did yes thank you